my 9/11 first responder I have four
different illnesses I get emotional I
talk about it I have established and
here because mr. Crowley started 9/11
emigrant freedom workers I which is its
raw 3250 and as it seemed like it's
gonna die in Congress and nobody has
picking it back up and since you have
taken over from him I would like to know
if you will continue that also I'm
Haitian immigrant and I would for lauren
Order SVU television show I've paid over
3 million valiant tests and I've been in
this country for 15-month years in our
face deportation first of all first of
all I'd like all of us to really
acknowledge the contributions that Paul
Yi surgeon was Paul that mr. Eliason
that mr. liason has made to our country
for our city
[Applause]
mr. 911 he's showing me a photo of him
at ground zero so I want to thank you I
want to thank you for your service and
their there are so many aspects to your
story that touch my core and it is like
why I do what I am doing because when I
hear the rhetoric of this president and
when I hear the rhetoric of so many
people talking about immigrants and
undocumented people as though they are
disposable and unworthy I think of
people like you and how wrong that is
how wrong it is for them to do that
because you're right you said you've
been here 51 years since so the fact
that you've been here 51 years and have
not been extended a path to citizenship
means that we were wrong not you were
wrong
[Applause]